the Joe Rogan experience how do you
forgive Bill Cosby like to take that the
idea that you're supposed to forgive
Lois which I think yes and then I don't
see a path for Bill Cosby to be forgiven
they don't see that path when you've
ruined the lives of how many people 50
plus when something is that heinous I
just don't think I think I'd like to
have you ruined their life you you
certainly certainly [ __ ] them up like
if you wake up and you're with Bill
Cosby you thought he's gonna take care
of you and your pants are down by your
ankles do you realize you [ __ ] you
while you're unconscious and he drugged
you yeah that is gonna [ __ ] your head up
it's gonna change what you think about
people that someone could just drug you
and treat you like meat your unconscious
they're doing things to you when you're
out cause you're saying what's our laws
of forgiveness well how do you forgive
that first of all you can't because he
doesn't admit it he never admits it
never even gets to the door right of
like of acceptance of forgiveness of
doing this penance or what if there is a
penance if there's anything you never do
ever he doesn't even get to did
everybody sit down with every room for
forgiveness that's a good question I
think you would probably open up the
door to more lawsuits sure I think you
would they would come storming in like
hail you know right yeah but I think I
know what you're saying is very smart
it's saying like we're saying we're
supposed to give someone like for
someone like Louie well what is the line
of when you don't forgive right what's
the line what is how what's the number
what's the line what's the atrocity like
what is it that we go
you can't forgive this person anymore
yeah what's the what's the line of
compassion like weird you were detail
line of compassion that's a good word
that's what it is
what is that ultimate where you go now
you can no longer from this moment
forward forgive this human being and the
problem is now here's where it gets
slippery if you decide you you're gonna
be the guy who says I'm gonna kill this
guy someone that actually kills him yeah
yeah if you decide if you live in a
company look that's what we're
essentially doing we're just doing it
slow but putting them in a cage right
right but if you were gonna really
decide hey we're gonna we're gonna
remove this guy from the population I
can't trust her with my kids we live in
a primitive society okay we live in some
some village type society thousands of
years ago right that's what we all did
what would we do when someone was like
that well we probably try to figure out
a way to get rid of them yeah you kill
him you'd have to kill yeah you'd have
to but you would have to figure out what
are the laws that allow someone to kill
somebody because you can't just let
people kill people because you let
people kill people then you just come up
with excuses to kill people right and
this is what people have done throughout
history whether it's the Mongols the
Romans let me just go throughout history
people if people [ __ ] killed people
because they could kill people so when
do you what like what is the moral
distinction that you have to make where
someone is they have done irreparable
harm but that changes over time right
right that and that continually changes
that's that's my point is like that will
never stop changing from from from
decade to decade from era to era what we
find deplorable now will not be
deplorable later and that see was so
many aspects of our culture yes
literature movies yes yeah the way we
restrict what so so what we're saying is
is there ever a line is there ever alone
does it ever exist does that idea of
like this is the cutoff does that really
exist because it's constantly moving
it's constantly changing
you know I I've said it a million times
I've never said what Louis did was okay
I think he has his issues I don't think
anybody has but I also think everybody
needs to investigate what happened and
find out it's all about what yes I'm
sure
let him talk about it find out what the
social psychology of what he was going
through yeah but disturbed but what I
think is happening too is that a lot of
women feel like when these guys that are
abusers got taken out that it made it so
that it was better for women and so that
if they come back things go back the way
they were this is a real that's a real
thought you know it's what we must have
conversation yeah we don't have
conversation then we're [ __ ]
[Applause]